astrazeneca für alle bund und länder
heben die priorisierung für den
impfstoff komplett auf mehr impfstoffe
für ärmere länder die usa planen den
patentschutz der hersteller auszusetzen
thomas tuchel wieder im finale der
champions league chelsea london besiegte
im halbfinale real madrid
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers abend hinein an diesem
donnerstag geben sie uns 20 minuten für
den nachrichtenüberblick den sport
steuert auch heute kristin otto bei und
nur erfreuliches guten abend wir
beginnen heute mit einer ganzen reihe
von nachrichten zum thema impfen
alle in deutschland können sich künftig
mit astrazeneca impfen lassen bund und
länder haben sich geeinigt die bisherige
priorisierung ist für diesen impfstoff
vom tisch hintergrund ist die tatsache
dass astrazeneca immer noch auf
vorbehalte bei manchen trifft volker
dutschek hat mehr dazu astrazeneca fünf
selbmann denen sich die geister scheiden
ein hin und her
erst sollten damit in deutschland
menschen nur unter 65 geimpft werden
dann bekommen nur noch über 60-jährige
den impfstoff künftig fällt die
altersbeschränkung bei erwachsenen
komplett weg das ist der kern eines
beschlusses der gesundheitsminister der
länder und des bundes zur astrazeneca
das heißt dass beim impfen in den
arztpraxen die ärzte entscheiden wer
jetzt wann mit dem impfen dran ist nach
ärztlichem vermessen die verunsicherung
in der bevölkerung spiegelt sich auch in
den erfahrungen von nicola bohlinger
göpfert die allgemeinmedizinerin and
ford zahlen wurde ihre astrazeneca dosen
einfach nicht los trotz langer
beratungsgespräche deswegen vererbte sie
kurzerhand 700 losen astrazeneca mit
kolleginnen auf dem parkplatz eines
supermarktes was vielen bei astrazeneca
angst macht das risiko von hirn
venenthrombosen das risiko für frauen
ist dreimal höher als bei männern
vor allem bei frauen unter 60 die
medizinische hochschule hannover hat als
erste klinik in deutschland eine
auswertung über die möglichen
nebenwirkungen veröffentlicht für die
wissenschaftler überwiegend bei
astrazeneca die vorteile gegenüber den
risiken komplikationen die auftreten
können wie lungenembolien sinus
venenthrombosen tiefe beinvenenthrombose
sind sind natürlich wenn sie früh
erkannt werden sehr rasch und einfach
behandelbar und
hey ländern üblicherweise ohne
begleitung nach folgen dann ab bund und
länder wollen auch einen nachteil von
astrazeneca beseitigen weil nämlich
vielen die bisher üblichen zwölf wochen
wartezeit zwischen erster und zweiter
impfung zu lang sind wird der abstand
verringert auf mindestens vier wochen
nach mehr freiheiten sehen sich auch
schülerinnen und schüler
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn hat
heute bekannt gegeben
alle zwölf bis 15 jährigen sollen im
sommer ein impfstoff angebot erhalten
dabei soll vor allem der impfstoff von
bei und tag eingesetzt werden des lang
ist der erst ab 16 freigegeben
mit einer zulassung für 12 bis 15
jährige wird im juni gerechnet
wir bleiben noch beim impfen patente
schützen geistiges eigentum auch dass
der impfstoff herstellern schließlich
haben sie erfolgreich geforscht und
wollen jetzt auch davon profitieren
doch ist das fair und angemessen
angesichts einer weltweiten pandemie us
präsident joe biden unterstützt jetzt
die forderung aus ärmeren ländern solche
patente erst einmal auszusetzen einfach
um weltweit überall mehr impfstoff
herstellen zu können
die bundesregierung äußerte sich
skeptisch aus europa heißt es man sei
offen für gespräche
eine klinik es ist nur ein nebensatz in
der pressekonferenz des us präsidenten
eigentlich will joe biden schon gehen da
kommt die frage ob er die forderung nach
einem verzicht auf impfstoff patente
unterstütze
darüber werde ich noch heute sprechen
bislang hatten sich die usa gegen die
erzwungene weitergabe von in freetz
ebbten ausgesprochen beiden satz weckt
nun hoffnung zum beispiel in afrika
angola etwa erhält bislang impfstoffe
aus der eu nur sechs länder in afrika
besitzen eigene produktionsstätten der 2
darum sind wir bereit darüber zu reden
wie der us vorschlag den schutz
geistigen eigentums bykow mit
impfstoffen aufzuheben helfen könnte
dieses ziel zu erreichen
active das ist auch ein schwenk der eu
kommission die bislang zwar über eine
ausweitung der produktion nicht aber
über patente reden wollte es braucht
eine umfassende patent aussetzung und
dann im zweiten schritt eben
einen technologietransfer die produktion
eines hochwirksamen m rna impfstoffs wie
der von bayern tag oder moderner aber
ist kompliziert rohstoffe und material
wie lipide oder glasfläschchen sind oft
knapp die ärmeren länder müssten mit den
etablierten herstellern konkurrieren
fabriken etwa von afrikanischen
medikamentenherstellern müssen
umgerüstet werden laut experten dauert
das mindestens sechs monate und
pharmazeutisches personal muss geschult
werden
auch dafür würden fachleute der
patentinhaber gebraucht die pharmafirmen
die in der krise viel geld vom staat
bekommen haben während sich trotzdem
gegen eine weitergabe ihres wissens ein
patent sei gerade ein anreiz für
wissenschaftler mit hochdruck zu
forschen nun die patente haben dafür
gesorgt dass wir mehr als 250 projekte
haben die forschenden in stufen
noch wichtiger als die patente so die
botschaft der europäer sei aber dass
herstellerländer impfstoffe exportierten
ein seitenhieb auf die usa
dort gilt immer noch ein exportverbot
und in die usa gehen wir jetzt
einbringen sonst zdf-korrespondenten
benjamin daniel in washington mit dazu
guten namen benjamín was sind denn die
gründe für präsident biden dass er jetzt
beim patentrecht umschwenkt meines
erachtens kann man drei hauptgründe
identifizieren erstens joe biden hat es
ja versprochen im wahlkampf damit bleibt
der sich seiner linie treu bedient seine
partei aber ausgerechnet in den usa sind
gerade geistiges eigentum patentrecht
urheberrecht so gut wie unantastbar und
deswegen hagelt das durchaus auch
scharfe kritik zb aus der wirtschaft zum
beispiel von konservativen medien von
republikanern
es gab einen schreckmoment an der börse
2 joe biden hat immer gesagt für wie
wichtig er die führungsrolle der usa in
der welt betrachtet und das untermauert
er mit dieser entscheidung jetzt
gewisser war es nochmal ausgerechnet den
pandemie zeiten und der dritte grund das
ist meiner meinung nach der gewichtigste
grund amerika ist importnation nummer 1
in der welt und gerade länder wie mexiko
und indien das sind die zellen zu den
top ten waren lieferanten und deswegen
hat joe biden ein gesteigertes interesse
daran dass auch in diesen ländern die
pandemie effizient bekämpft wird schnell
bekämpft wird das liefert
hätten geschlossen werden um über diesen
hebel mittelbar sozusagen auch die
heimische wirtschaft weiter anzukurbeln
interessante hintergründe live aus
washington benjamin vielen dank auch
heute ein positiver trend bei den corona
zahlen in deutschland das robert koch
institut meldet 21 1953 fälle innerhalb
von 24 stunden das sind 2783 weniger als
vor einer woche 250 menschen starben in
zusammenhang mit 19 immer größer wird
die zahl der geimpften eine erste dosis
haben inzwischen knapp 25 einhalb
millionen menschen erhalten
das entspricht einer quote von 30,6
prozent vollständig geimpft sind 7,1
millionen menschen 8,6 prozent der
bevölkerung
und diese vollständig gegen korona
geimpften und die genesenen sollen
wieder mehr rechte zurückbekommen das
hat der bundestag heute beschlossen die
erleichterungen könnten schon am
wochenende greifen
und darum geht es im einzelnen keine
nächtliche ausgangssperre mehr kontakt
beschränkungen werden gelockert
geimpfte dürfen ohne test vorher in
geschäfte oder zum friseur und nach
reisen müssen sie nicht mehr in
quarantäne
es sei denn sie kommen aus einem
sogenannten virusvarianten gebiet mehr
zur debatte dazu heute im parlament von
bernd benthin
die bundesjustizministerin verteidigt
mit nachdruck die neue rechtsverordnung
wo immer freiheit möglich sei müsse sie
auch gewährt werden
meine damen und herren über was reden
wir denn da wir reden darüber dass in
zukunft menschen die im pflegeheim über
monate hinweg keine kontakte mehr hatten
alleine in ihren zimmern essen mussten
und es schmerzhaft auch gespürt haben
dass die ihn sofort wieder ein
speisesaal zusammen essen können die afg
stimmt gegen die verordnung sie fordert
eine sofortige rücknahme aller
schutzmaßnahmen
mit der vorliegenden verordnung wollen
sie kämpften oder genesenen mitmenschen
einen teil ihrer verfassungsmäßig
verbriefte grundrechte wiedergeben
jedoch werden millionen andere weiterhin
diskriminiert
es ist unglaublich was sie hier
vorgetragen haben sprechen sie auch
darüber warum wir dieses grundrecht
einschränken
wir schränken es deshalb ein anderes zur
geltung zu bringen nämlich das recht auf
körperliche unversehrtheit die fdp
enthielt sich bei der abstimmung und
kritisiert die verordnung gingen nicht
weit genug
es ist auch nicht ersichtlich warum der
gastronom der selbst geimpft ist sein
lokal nicht zur genesene und geimpfte
öffnen kann
unser grundgesetz in artikel 12 auch die
berufsfreiheit
die grünen und die linke stimmen mit der
regierung mahnen aber gleichzeitig mehr
unterstützung für jüngere er noch
ungeimpfte an
gerade eltern junger familien oder
studierende und auszubildende dürfen wir
nicht vergessen
die bundesregierung und die
eu-kommission tragen die volle
verantwortung dafür dass die kapazitäten
hinsichtlich der impfstoffe so gering
waren das bisher nur acht prozent
unserer bevölkerung vollständig geimpft
sind
das ist ein einzigartiger skandal schon
am sonntag soll die verordnung in kraft
treten letzte hürde davor der bundesrat
morgen
und so viele dieser sendung zunächst zum
thema corona die neuen deutschen
klimaziele gehen vielen in der
wirtschaft zu weit so müssen die
energieerzeuger laut dem gesetzentwurf
der regierung bis 2030 rund 30 prozent
mehr co2 einsparen als bisher geplant
von blindem aktionismus spricht der
bundesverband der industrie und
befürchtet wettbewerbsnachteile für
deutsche firmen die autoindustrie und
die ig metall warnen vor dem verlust von
arbeitsplätzen und jetzt gucken wir nach
großbritannien kurz nach dem wechsel sah
sich das land im kampf gegen korona mit
vielen toten aber auch mit vielen
impfungen im rekordtempo wie sich das
alles auf die politische stimmung
auswirkt werden wohl die heutigen
regionalwahlen zeigen besonders spannend
ist es in schottland denn die
nationalpartei hofft auf ein top
ergebnis um von der zentralregierung in
london
das zugeständnis zu erreichen dass die
schotten ein zweites mal über die
unabhängigkeit abstimmen dürfen
wie die chancen stehen zeigt diana
zimmermann gebannt blickt großbritannien
heute nach schottland dort wird gewählt
und es geht nicht nur um die 129 sitze
für das regionale parlament sondern
womöglich um die zukunft des königreichs
je größer der sieg der schottischen
nationalpartei bei diesen wahlen desto
nachdrücklicher wird nicholas deutschen
ein referendum über schottlands
unabhängigkeit fordern
diese waren sind wirklich wichtig das
land erlebt die größte krise an die wir
uns erinnern können
wir müssen mit einer starken erfahrenen
führung durch die pandemie kommen um
dann die nächsten entscheidungen treffen
zu können und die das finden mit station
auch die grünen müssten in richtung
unabhängigkeit führen
konservative und labour wollen in der
union mit england bleiben so wie vor
allem die älteren schotten
ich denke es hat wirklich halte das mit
der unabhängigkeit für einen großen
fehler man sieht ja was für ein chaos
der brh exit ist wären wir unabhängig
hätten wir mehr autonomie london
entscheidet immer ein bisschen über uns
hinweg
wenn man den 4,3 millionen
wahlberechtigte gibt es schon mit 16
dürfen die jungen schotten über ihre
politische zukunft mit entscheiden
ein klarer vorteil für die
unabhängigkeit parteien
denn je jünger die wähler desto eher
sind sie für die trennung von england
boris johnson will ein zweites
referendum natürlich unbedingt
verhindern
wie millionen anderer wählte er heute
selbst allerdings bei den englischen
kommunalwahlen deren ausgang gilt als
wichtiger stimmungstest für die
regierung und ihren umgang mit der
korona krise ergebnis am wochenende
es hat den anschein als taumelnde
kolumbien gerade wieder zurück in dunkle
zeiten seiner geschichte sagen
hilfsorganisationen angst und gewalt
sind zurück seit tagen gibt es proteste
gegen die regierung dabei kommt es immer
wieder zu gewaltsamen
auseinandersetzungen zwischen
demonstranten und der polizei mindestens
24 menschen haben ihr leben verloren
auslöser für die proteste war ein
inzwischen zurückgenommener vorschlag
für eine steuerreform
der vor allem die untere und die
mittelschicht belastet hätte
mittlerweile richten sich die
demonstrationen auch gegen das harte
vorgehen der kolumbianischen
sicherheitskräfte und sehr ernste
nachrichten kommen auch aus madagaskar
vor hunger müssen die menschen dort
blätter und wurzeln essen die uno
schlägt alarm die insel vor der
südostküste afrikas hat mehrere dürre
jahre hintereinander erlebt der südteil
von madagaskar ist schwer getroffen mehr
als eine millionen menschen brauchen
hilfe sandra times berichtet
hilfseinsatz des welternährungsprogramms
in trun omarow einem dorf im süden
madagaskars drei kinder sind in
kritischem zustand zappa source zwei
jahre alt ihre mutter hat sie zu dieser
krankenstation gebracht
eines meiner kinder ist gestorben
wir haben es freitag begraben mit diesem
bin ich hierher gekommen
ein helfer versucht den einzigen
vorhandenen krankenwagen zu organisieren
das krankenhaus ist zwei stunden
entfernt
der süden des landes erlebt die
schlimmste hungerkrise seit langem
grund ist eine jahrelange dürre
außerdem machen sandstürme viele felder
unfruchtbar
die menschen suchen verzweifelt nach
allem was essbar ist seit fast zwei
jahren haben wir nichts mehr geerntet
wir mussten uns von wurzelknollen
ernähren seit es geregnet hat sind die
larven der heuschrecken geschlüpft das
hat uns gerettet ohne die heuschrecken
wären wir schon alle tobt das land
steuere auf eine humanitäre katastrophe
zu sagen die helfer die lage ist extrem
schlecht
eine hungersnot droht im süden
madagaskars die menschen erleben wie
fast alle nahrungsquellen verschwinden
wir haben einen massiven nährstoff
notstand zappa hat glück der
krankenwagen ist auf dem weg zumindest
für den moment hat sie eine chance zu
überleben wenn sie den menschen im osten
von afrika helfen möchten das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat ein
spendenkonto eingerichtet stichwort zdf
hunger in afrika
hier ist die bahn de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 weitere informationen unter
spenden zdf de oder im zdf text ab seite
800 90 so und jetzt in der sendung hatte
uns christin positive nachrichten
versprochen
genau ein beispiel die blues
hochstimmung dort nur um durch den fc
chelsea
drei tage nach den frauen des vereins
stehen auch die männer im finale der
champions league und sichern ein
englisches endspiel in der königsklasse
das 2 0 im halbfinal rückspiel gegen
real madrid beeindruckt
vier deutsche haben daran einen großen
anteil mit trainer tuchel und den
nationalspielern rüdiger herz und werner
letztere sorgen nach vorarbeit des
überragenden kantee für die verdiente
führung habe als elegant werner veredelt
zum 10
wir können die champions league gewinnen
dazu den fa-cup unser team ist
unglaublich
real findet kaum eine lücke im chelsea
bollwerk die blues dagegen mit
zahlreichen vergebenen großchancen mason
brown trifft erst spät zum beruhigen
wenn 20
[Applaus]
noch ist nichts geschafft wir haben zwei
endspiele vor uns das finale gegen
manchester city ist für thomas tuchel
das zweite champions league endspiel
nacheinander mit zwei unterschiedlichen
klubs das gab es noch nie in der
finalrunde der deutschen eishockey liga
haben sich die eisbären berlin
zurückgemeldet und das entscheidende
dritte spiel erzwungen
nach der knappen auftaktniederlage
setzen sich nun die berliner in
wolfsburg mit 4 1 durch die eisbären
haben den grizzlys die meisterfeier
vorerst verdorben
anders als bei der 2 3-heimniederlage
zeigten sie hier hört mit dem 1 0 in
wolfsburg von anfang an einen
unbedingten siegeswillen markieren mit
dem zweiten und kurz darauf streuen mit
dem dritten treffer gaben der partie
eine deutliche richtung
daran konnte auch der treffer der
grizzlys durch fauser nichts mehr ändern
als wolfsburg dann um alles oder nichts
spiel vieles reiche leicht den 4 zu 1
endstand zu markieren
das entscheidende dritte spiel findet
nun morgen abend in berlin bei den
heißgelaufenen eisbären statt elf wochen
vor beginn der olympischen sommerspiele
in tokio wurde in düsseldorf die
bekleidung des deutschen olympischen und
des paralympischen teams vorgestellt
neben den klassischen schwarz rot gold
farben wird das so genannte team dem
auch in frischen wind und gelbtönen
auftreten und alles natürlich sehr sehr
funktional eben der hitze in tokio
angepasst frische mint töne
ich habe viele neon gesehen aber guten
besonderen moment darüber nachdenken
vielen dank dass ich es kann ja nicht
schaden besonders lässige menschen immer
mal so im blick zu haben vielleicht kann
man sich was abgucken baseball
philadelphia gegen die new york mets
mehr als 100 stundenkilometer schnell
saust ein ball auf die tribüne
und dann das er fängt den ball hält sein
eis bekommt applaus und verliebte blicke
erfolg macht attraktiv das wetter der
mai zeigt sich sommerlich zum wochenende
schöne details also gleich von katja
oliver dann empfehle ich ihnen das heute
journal mit der kollegin marietta slomka
um 21 uhr 45 und der geschichte eines
stuhls auf dem wohl jeder auf dieser
welt schon mal gesessen ist
wir sind morgen wieder für sie da für
heute danke dass sie dabei waren und in
hallen ein angenehmer
[Musik]